So you want me to record 15 milliseconds
(15,000, 1,500, how many? ) Yeah, 15 (That makes 15)
1000. 15,000 is 15 seconds. (Okay, go on then)
Right
There we are. Is this thing on?
Hello and welcome to Computerphile
I think that looks pretty good here.
(I kind of wanted a bit of advice because I've bought this Raspberry Pi 4, and it seemed pretty powerful)
(So I thought, why not try and make a video on it?)
(I just want to see if I can)
(If it could do video editing, right?)
Ok, so presumably you want me to put it together?
(Yeah go on then)
Ok, I bought one of these too when they came out there. They are incredibly powerful machines for what they are.
We've now got a quad-core
CPU and again, it's been upgraded from before
The RAM is now separate
We've got 4 GB of RAM on here instead of one GB
The thing that interested me most is Gigabit Ethernet
USB 3, which means we've got pretty decent connectivity off this and get 5 gigabits per second
I think off here one gigabit a second off that, got some USB 2 ports for things like keyboard and so on so it's great
well, I mean
I think lots of interesting things you can do. We did some interesting things the other week with the Raspberry Pi 3
It's got the potential we're feeding, we definitely know we can feed 30 megabits per second video to these things
And they can cope so you've got, you've got enough - a chance with this. So let's get it up and running for you
What else have we got here? I see you've been off shopping at Pimoroni
(To be fair and even-handed some of that stuff came from The Pi Hut as well.)
Okay, so other Pi shops are available. So what have we got? We've got heat sinks, these things do get warm. So they're quite good
but we also have
The Pi fan as well. Let's start with that. Let's start with the fan and put the heat sinks on as well
if we need to because it works better and
we've got a camera
and a power supply. Let's move over to the other desk and we'll start building this. We've also got a battery power
source and a monitor over here. Yes, but let's actually see if it works first before we start building things
Dodgy old keyboard and mouse here from
Goodness knows when. So we've got a NOOBS
SD card in there
One thing you have forgotten to give me
(go on)
batteries
(batteries?)
Power, yep
So be interesting to know how long we could power this off a battery to, um
See if we could film with it. So the other nice thing we've got dual
HDMI, I think that's HDMI zero so that's going to there, so that hopefully
Should now boot.
See what we've got. It's doing something, the lights have come on, let's turn the monitor on
Woohoo
1080p60
Looking good so far
And it's booting into Raspbian
Resizing the file system, rebooting in five seconds. So it's all working
I always use them from the command line. So I'm never used to the
Things
So hopefully that will shut down, there we are, that looks like it shutdown
So let's put this together
Now sure, and we'll now edit this as a nice montage with some music
*Nice Music*
One thing I tend to do when building these things is put the screws in upside down to start with because that way
It holds things together as you sort of stack things
*More nice music*
(So why is there a right way and a wrong way?)
I don't know, I just think the pointy bits work better as feet than the non-pointy bits
So there we have a thing built. The other thing we do is put the fan shim on just to keep it nice and cool
These things run fine without it, but they do start to throttle, if you're going to be video editing on it
It might get a little
over-warm
So what we end up in this package is fan from there, a little control board
Which the fan screws into
And that one'll pop on once it's assembled. So you should attach the fan to this first
(This is an elaborate ruse to get you to build it for me Steve)
I'm getting that impression
Several hours later. We got the
Thing in and now this just clips over the GPIO pin so you can still use them
Like that, and now it'll now blow nice cold air
onto
The system for us. But you've got me another toy as well, haven't you, Sean?
You've got another toy which is a cog
Some more that I think it's the camera module
Now the one thing I found with these cameras is that they do not like being touched
This seems to be some sort of focus control. So we'll pull that, now this is now right in the way
So we'll take that off
So you just pop that in there
That looks like it's in place, we've now got the camera
Attached. Can pop this furnishing back on
Making sure to get it accurately lined up over the pins. Quite a clever design
We going to shoot it on this camera as well? (Let's see what we can achieve) All right.
(So that colored screen, that's the POST, is it?) Yeah
Yeah, the bootloader displays out on the GPU and then it loads the kernel off the SD card and eventually the kernel starts up
And we're into NOOBS. So I think I need to configure the
Camera first so the fans running, it's blowing air down. (Nice and quiet. That's good.) Yep. We could find out how
Cold the CPU is, measure temp
Thirty nine point zero degrees. So we're going to turn on the interfacing options. We want the camera
Enabled, yes
Camera enabled. Excellent
Would you like to reboot now? Yes
So if we do "raspivid -f"
There we are. Of course the cameras upside down (whoah)
(So you're going through looking at the options and just appending them to a) Command line
"-r test.mp4"
So there we have it there Sean. So it's working, you just need to work how to record with it
Stopping us loading a different program's coding data again from storage into memory as well
And then we can start that program instead. kind of invertible and that's something statistically weaker
But if you didn't do that, right?
So there's a rules you should be careful about when you're designing these kind of things